[Música]
en medio del conflicto armado que vivió
mi país colombia la banda de mauricio le
disparó ocho veces a juan juan fue
llevado al hospital entre la vida y la
muerte
allí se quedó un año seis meses en
cuidados intensivos y cuando salió se
dio cuenta que había perdido para
siempre la movilidad del lado izquierdo
de su cuerpo mauricio
decidió pedirle perdón a juan tres años
después en medio del proceso de paz y
reconciliación y decidió pedirle perdón
frente a una cámara a la mía todo esto
ocurre en el documental camino el perdón
que realice en el año 2007
pero cuando por fin tenía esta gran
historia cuando por fin había logrado
esto que tanto anhelamos todos los
periodistas
mi vida había cambiado porque yo ahora
no solamente quería contar historias
yo quería cambiar el mundo yo quería
ayudar a transformar esas historias
porque caminando por las calles de
medellín en medio de la violencia y el
dolor me di cuenta que la guerra es la
hija de la desesperanza y donde no hay
esperanza no hay posibilidad de soñar y
ahí fue que encontré el camino los
sueños y comencé a hablar de los sueños
dondequiera que podía en las cárceles en
las universidades en los colegios donde
había un espacio yo hablaba de sueños y
fue tanto el amor que tuve por esta
posibilidad de cambiar el mundo que
diseñé
este lienzo
con la posibilidad de hacer que cada
persona pueda hacer su propia versión de
su vida y de su sueño
es el lienzo de los sueños es la
planeación estratégica para volverlo
realidad y tiene cinco pasos para
construir un sueño usted lo quiere
conocer
los quieren conocer muy bien estos pasos
son decidir
planear
inicial
avanzar y lograr
para poder lograr el reto es enorme
porque lo que nos toca es todos los días
trabajar un poquito y como nuestra
obsesión es esta nosotros decidimos
crear una joya y con esta joya cada vez
que vas avanzando en la construcción de
un sueño vas pasando un impulsor de
sueños de atrás para adelante así cada
vez que vas avanzando lo tienes contigo
nosotros hemos llegado con nuestra
metodología a más de 3000 personas en
colombia y queremos seguir haciéndolo y
hoy que estoy frente a ustedes con toda
esta felicidad de saber que se cumplen
los sueños puedo decirles desde el fondo
de mi corazón que si cumples tu sueño y
cambias el mundo muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]